Ein richtiger Teekessel!
Er ist so schrecklich,
dass er schon wieder lässig ist.
Willst du reinschauen?
Öffne den Deckel!
Ho, ho!
Da habe ich eine alte Büchse.
Es gibt nur noch welche aus Karton.
Das ist natürlich
schon ein schönes Stück.
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
Kindheitserinnerungen?
- Ja, ja.
* Drollige Musik *
Können Sie dieses Ding brauchen?
Brauchen nicht, nein. Aber zum
Lernen, was es für Holzarten gibt.
Zum Lernen
finde ich es sehr schön.
Wir kommen fast jeden Samstag.
Einfach zum Schauen ...
Wir sind Stammkunden.
- ... was es Neues gibt.
Was machen Sie mit all den Sachen?
Das schenke ich dem Patenkind.
Das ist zum Basteln mit der Tochter.
Billig und es sind gute Sachen.
(Mann) Viele Leute.
Wer nicht ins Brocki geht,
verpasst etwas. - Stimmt.
Es ist die Sammelleidenschaft,
die Menschen ins Brockenhaus bringt.
Die pure Not
oder die Schnäppchenjagd.
Wieder andere setzen hier ein Zeichen
gegen die Wegwerfmentalität.
* Quirlige Akkordeonmusik *
Was suchen und finden Menschen
im Brocki?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
* Quirlige Akkordeonmusik *
Ein Messer?
Das ist gut.
- Billig.
Das ist mega günstig.
Haben Sie eine neue Katze?
Ja, wir haben alle Katzen.
- Katzenfanatiker.
Die ganze Familie
hat zu Hause Katzen.
Was haben Sie ausserdem gekauft?
- Ja ...
Kleider.
- Wir schauen nach Kleidern.
Ich habe ein T-Shirt gekauft.
- Buch ...
Ein ideales T-Shirt zum Arbeiten.
Ein Samstagmorgen im Brockenhaus
des Blauen Kreuzes in St. Gallen.
Sie sind im Kaufrausch!
- Das kann man so sagen.
Aber letzen Endes wird es mich
vielleicht 30 Fr. kosten,
ich weiss es nicht.
Kaufen Sie immer oder
häufig im Brocki ein? - Meistens.
Ich mag die grossen Geschäfte nicht
und die Kleider sind alle gleich.
Ja.
Und ich finde es schade, dass
heutzutage so viel weggeworfen wird.
Wir haben einen Überschuss
an Material.
Ich finde es super,
dass es wiederverwertet wird.
Da hat es viele Schätze.
So gut!
Wozu brauchen Sie all die Sachen?
Ja, eigentlich brauchen ...
Das ist immer so eine Sache.
Gekommen bin ich
wegen den Einmachgläsern.
Ich habe gehofft,
es hätte mehr davon.
Ich möchte viel Konfitüre kochen
und Früchte einmachen,
die ich heute
auf dem Bauernmarkt eingekauft habe.
Und z.B.
dieser wunderbare Erdbeerteekrug.
Den nehme ich für
den Schrebergarten mit. Der passt.
Eine neue Brotbox
brauche ich eigentlich schon lange.
Genau, ich lege sie rasch hin.
Eigentlich komme ich
immer wieder ins Brocki,
weil man hier Sachen findet,
die sonst kaum mehr erhältlich sind
und die ich auch gut für meinen Be-
ruf als Foodstylistin brauchen kann.
Aha.
- Genau.
Das lasse ich noch hier.
Nächste Woche habe ich etwas,
bei dem es um Vermicelles geht.
Dazu kann ich
ein Maronimesser super brauchen.
Es muss einfach mal ...
Wie wird man Foodstylistin?
Ja, also wirklich ...
Eine Schule oder so gibt es nicht.
Hierzulande nicht.
Ähm ... Ich bin gelernte Köchin.
Nebst verschiedenen Berufsstationen
bin ich irgendwann einmal
in einer Rezeptredaktion gelandet.
Ich habe dann für ... ähm ... ja.
Für Schweizer Kochmagazine habe ich
ein paar Jahre Rezepte geschrieben.
Und so bin ich eigentlich
in das Foodstyling hineingekommen,
also das Essen für die Fotos
meiner Rezepte schön präsentieren.
Mein Brocki-Fundus.
* Piepsen *
Noch etwas hinein ...
Der Rahm war vorher besser.
Mhm.
Das schöne Maronimesser
ist nun gar nicht im Einsatz.
Es passt doch nicht dazu.
Wenn ich zu den fertigen Produkten
noch das Maroni-Schnitzmesser ...
Das würde sich beissen,
gerade im Bezug auf die Produkte,
die wir zeigen möchten.
Ginge es darum,
eine Maroniernte zu zeigen ...
Oder irgendwie ...
Zu einem stimmungsvollen Bild aus
dem Tessin wäre es ideal gewesen.
Das ist Millimeterarbeit.
Am Ende sieht es aus,
als würde es zufällig so dastehen.
Das ist die Kunst am Ganzen,
im Gegensatz zu früher,
als Foodstyling ganz anders war
und man Nagellack und Haarspray
benutzte - richtig künstlich also -
damit der Apfel dann wirklich
wie aus dem Märchen aussah.
Heute ist es etwas ...
Heute sollte es so wirken, als
sei es einfach hingeworfen worden
und trotzdem gut aussehen.
Heutzutage
ist es eigentlich wirklich so,
dass wir die Produkte praktisch
ausnahmslos nachher noch essen.
(Frau, leise) Noch etwas abdrehen.
Also ich freue mich heute
noch auf das Dessert.
Gut.
Wir rufen sie mal.
- Es sieht sehr gut aus.
Wir sagen nun einfach ...
Da kommt der Löffel
mehr zur Geltung.
Was wir noch gemacht haben: Wir
haben frische Würmchen gepresst.
Ja, weil es sonst
zu stark zusammenfällt.
Das kann man kaum zeigen.
Nach 2 Std. Fotoshooting:
Daumen hoch von der Redaktion
des "Migros-Magazins":
Es ist cool.
- Nicht wahr, oder?
Zudem finde ich das Licht
mega schön.
Diese Stimmung ...
Sie werden nicht gleich gut,
ich lasse es.
Sind Sie zufrieden?
- Ja, sehr.
Es zeigt auf, dass man aus einem
Produkt, von dem man zuerst denkt:
"Meine Güte! Wie schaffe ich es,
dass es gut wirkt?"
auch ein so schönes,
stimmiges Bild hinkriegt.
Das find ich halt schon sehr cool.
Auch die Zusammenarbeit.
Es ist ein Prozess, der entsteht.
Genau.
* Quirlige Akkordeonmusik *
Die sind gut.
Ja, die nehme ich.
Kaufen Sie oft im Brockenhaus ein?
- Ja, Jacken und Pullis, sehr gerne.
Warum? - Weil es sie
in den Läden nicht gibt.
Hier finde ich etwas Spezielles,
das nicht jeder hat.
Also wir brauchen sie
für die Schule.
Wir gehen ins Appenzell.
Auf die Schulreise?
Es ist einfach die Atmosphäre,
das Feeling und das Suchen.
Das ist wunderschön.
Die Schnäppchenjagd?
- Ja, genau.
Ich habe eine schöne Jacke
für meinen Partner gefunden.
Die ist praktisch neu.
Nehmen Sie sie? - Ja, ich stelle sie
noch der Familie
und der Kollegin vor
und schaue dann.
Das sind Pyjamas.
Fünf, sechs, sieben sogar.
Wir wohnen auf einem Bio-Hof.
Ich habe unten einen Kachelofen.
Oben sind es im Winter etwa 16 °C.
Ja, da muss man sich im Bett
warm anziehen.
Wenn man so gerne liest wie wir,
also unsere ganze Familie,
dann geht das irgendwann ins Geld.
Ich kaufe ein Buch für 25 Fr.
und dann gefällt es mir nicht.
Bei 3 Fr. kann ich sagen:
"Okay, ich habe mich
bis in die Mitte durchgekämpft,
aber es passt mir nicht,
ich lege es auf den Stapel
fürs Brocki."
Hallo.
- Grüezi.
Wer seine ausgedienten Sachen
hier abgibt,
entrümpelt nicht nur seine Wohnung.
Der Gang ins Brocki ist
auch eine Spende an das Blaue Kreuz.
In den Dienst der Suchtprävention
stellen sich mit ihrer Arbeit
auch die 30 freiwilligen Mitarbeiter
und Mitarbeiterinnen des Brocki.
Ich bin wegen meines Mannes
zum Blauen Kreuz gekommen.
Mein Mann ist Alkoholiker.
Ich bin ... Vor Jahren
bin ich beinahe verzweifelt
und hätte den Bettel
am liebsten hingeworfen.
Ich bin in die Mitenand-Gruppe.
Da konnten alle kommen und man hat
über die Probleme gesprochen, ...
... die es einfach gibt.
Im Vergleich zu anderen ist
mein Mann eigentlich noch heilig.
Man erfährt so viele Dinge und man
weiss, dass man nicht alleine ist.
Und Sie selbst? Sie trinken nichts,
keinen Alkohol?
Nein. Ich habe schon früher
nicht viel getrunken,
einzig zum Anstossen.
Mit der Zeit wurde ich dann
zu 100 % abstinent.
Ich habe auch ... Das ist, äh ...
In St. Gallen und im Appenzell
ist es so, dass man unterschreibt.
Also man hat
als Mitglied unterschrieben.
Und ich bin einfach überzeugt davon.
Viele Kundinnen und Kunden ihrerseits
sind überzeugt von der Nachhaltigkeit
des Modells Brocki.
Deren Credo: Weniger ist mehr.
Alles, was ich in mein Leben hole,
verlangt von mir Zeit,
Aufmerksamkeit, Pflege.
Je mehr Zeit ich
mit Dingen verbringen muss, -
umräumen, pflegen,
reparieren, benutzen -
desto weniger Zeit habe ich
für die Dinge,
die mir eigentlich wichtig wären.
Ohne ständig denken zu müssen:
"Ich sollte den Keller räumen."
Oder dass man zu Hause Dinge hat,
die einen so vorwurfsvoll anschauen.
"Du solltest dich um mich kümmern,
mich reparieren, mich wegbringen."
Je weniger ich reinlasse, desto we-
niger muss ich wegwerfen, ausmisten.
"Verschenken"
ist auch so eine Angewohnheit.
Man mutet seinen Ramsch
den liebsten Menschen zu.
Das ist auch nicht unbedingt
eine nette Geste.
Insofern bin ich
sehr wählerisch geworden,
aber ich habe dagegen
höhere Qualitätsansprüche.
Was haben Sie noch gefunden?
* Sie lacht. *
Wir haben noch dieses Buch gefunden,
ganz interessant.
Es ist schon lange auf dem Markt.
- Zwei T-Shirts.
* Er spricht spanisch. *
Die gefällt mir.
Sie ist sehr schön und elegant.
Sie sitzt wie angegossen.
Man bringt mir sicher Respekt
entgegen, wenn ich sie trage.
Richtig cool!
* Drollige Akkordeonmusik *
Dort hinten wo die beiden Herren
sind, habe ich ein Abtropfteil.
Du kannst sie mir geben.
- Es hat noch viel mehr.
Hat's noch Kleider
oder hast du gleich alle genommen?
Es hat noch zwei, drei.
Die Unschönen sind noch da.
* Drollige Akkordeonmusik *
Und, funktioniert er?
Ist das alles?
- Das ist alles.
(Mann) Gelesen habe ich
von diesem Modell schon viel.
Ich habe es zufällig gesehen.
Ich bin ein Brocki-Fan.
- Sicher?
Ja, schon seit vielen Jahren.
Ich sammle auch wie wahnsinnig.
- Was denn?
Ich sammle v.a. Bauernbrauchtum.
Mhm.
Mein ganzer Hobbyraum
ist voll davon.
So, das macht nun ...
Schau mal den Preis,
den du bezahlst,
für den Haufen, den du hast.
Nein, noch nicht alle.
Es ist günstig,
im Brockenhaus einzukaufen.
Aber manchen Menschen
ist es trotzdem zu teuer hier.
Diebstahl ist Alltag im Brocki.
Eine Mitarbeiterin
hat heute ein Regal geräumt.
Jetzt sehen wir hier ...
Wir haben z.B.
einen Staubsaugerbeutel.
Er hätte 1 Fr. gekostet.
Sie hat das nun gefunden
und gemerkt,
dass der Staubsaugerbeutel
nicht mehr drin ist.
Dann haben wir hier
viele solcher Zettelchen,
die einfach abgerissen wurden.
Da stehen teils massive Beträge.
Das hier war etwas aus Leder, 18 Fr.
Hier etwas in Grösse 38.
Es sind alles Textilsachen.
Die Leute reissen das Zettelchen weg
und man kann nicht mehr beweisen,
dass es bei uns hing.
Warum stehlen die Leute die Sachen,
die ohnehin schon günstig sind?
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass es beim Einen wirklich
eine Verzweiflungstat ist.
Er sagt: "Ich habe
so wenig Geld zur Verfügung."
Oder eine alleinerziehende Mutter,
bei der vielleicht
jemand nicht bezahlt
und am Existenzminium
leben muss, die dann sagt,
sie könne gar nicht anders.
Das sind echte Kristalle.
Das ist eine Maria Theresia.
Da ist das Tellerchen kaputt.
Das ist eine Lampe
aus den 50er-Jahren.
Oh, das ist
eine schöne Maria Theresia.
Man muss sie halt noch waschen.
Warum kennen Sie sich so aus?
Ich habe es im Auge.
(Lachend) Und in den Händen.
Eliane Vilarino
ist Stammkundin im Brockenhaus
und Besitzerin des Hotels Am Ring
in St. Gallen.
Alles, was hier steht und hängt,
hat sie im Brockenhaus
oder bei Villenauflösungen erstanden.
Ich habe das Gastgewerbe
von der Pike auf gelernt.
Was ich hier mache,
ist also schon ein Hobby.
Das ist mehr als ein Hobby,
beinahe eine Besessenheit.
Ja, ja, ich bin etwas angefressen.
Das bin ich, das stimmt.
So, den habe ich gewaschen.
Ist der auch aus der Brocki?
- Ja.
Nun muss ich schauen, was da fehlt.
Es hat Teile, die fehlen.
Die muss ich nun ...
Ich muss sie irgendwo aufhängen.
Ich habe kaum mehr Platz.
Früher konnte ich nichts verkaufen.
Bei der ersten Lampe, die ich ver-
kaufte, musste ich beinahe weinen.
Ich sehe diesen Mann
heute noch vor mir.
Er war Klavierbauer und er sagte:
"Diese Lampe gefällt mir gut."
Es war eine sehr schöne Lampe.
Ich wollte sie nicht hergeben
und meine Mutter sagte zu mir:
"So, und jetzt gib diese Lampe her,
du hast noch genügend!"
Also habe ich sie verkauft.
Seit diesem Tag konnte ich
ab und zu eine loslassen.
Vor 43 Jahren hat Eliane Vilarino
das Hotel eröffnet,
unterstützt von ihrer Mutter,
die damals selbst noch Pächterin
eines Restaurants war.
Es lief wie verrückt!
Meine Mutter meinte,
sie müsse mir helfen.
Wir haben das sehr lange gemacht.
Und, ja ...
Ich habe angefangen,
dieses und jenes zu sammeln.
Und, dem Mann ...
Ja, dem gefiel das nicht so gut.
Er sammelte eher Frauen.
Deswegen ist die Ehe
dann auch zerbrochen.
Ich sagte mir, ich müsse nun die
ganze Energie ins Haus stecken.
Wir haben mit Nichts
hier angefangen.
Wir hatten wirklich nichts.
Alles, was wir erarbeitet haben,
steckten wir wieder in das Haus.
Zwölf Hotelzimmer auf fünf Etagen
und kein Quadratzentimeter
ohne die dazugehörige Anekdote -
das ist Eliane Vilarinos Reich.
Die Zimmer strich ich immer selbst.
Ich war mit dem Roller am Streichen
und wenn es unten klingelte,
musste ich halt nach unten
und den Empfang machen.
Ich drehte sofort meine Kleider um.
Ich drehte meine Hose um.
So war ich wieder sauber
und ich sprang nach unten.
Ich machte den Empfang
und wenn ich wieder oben war,
drehte ich die Kleider
und strich wieder weiter.
Ich war voll. Auf dem Kopf
trug ich immer einen Hut.
So.
Die bleiben.
- Ja.
Seit fünf Jahren führt sie das Haus
zusammen mit ihrem Sohn Raffael.
So, für den Herrn Doktor
ein Krawättchen.
Haben Sie auch immer alleine geputzt
und die Wäsche gemacht? Alles?
Es gibt sehr viel Zeit, in der man
auf die Hotelgäste warten muss.
Währen dieser Zeit kann man gut
ein klein wenig arbeiten.
Ein klein wenig -
Sie haben den ganzen Tag geackert.
Ja, ich war schon immer etwas dran.
* Sie lacht.*
Ja.
Also man muss schon Freude haben.
Ich hatte Freude an allem, aber ...
Das Putzen gehört ja dazu.
Das muss man zu Hause auch.
Dort hat man nicht so viele Zimmer.
Ja, aber ich mache es
beinahe schon im Schlaf.
So.
Raffael macht hier
noch ein Krawättchen.
* Beide lachen. *
Es ist immer wichtig,
dass er ein Krawättchen hat.
* Sie lacht. *
Das ist sein Markenzeichen.
So.
Und man geht nur einmal
zum Schrank im Flur.
Man nimmt die ganze Wäsche mit,
um nicht zweimal laufen zu müssen.
So.
Das muss jetzt
noch alles gebügelt werden?
Ja, aber das habe ich
rasch gebügelt.
Also ...
Ich bügle täglich etwa 2 Std.
Wir müssen schauen, dass wir
mit den Preisen unten bleiben.
Die Leute schauen halt
immer noch sehr aufs Geld.
Die Siebentagewochen
haben Eliane Vilarino müde gemacht.
Ihr Sohn will in seinen gelernten
Beruf als Buchhalter zurück.
Darum hat sie sich entschieden,
das Hotel zu verkaufen.
Ja, also im Moment
habe ich schon etwas genug.
Jetzt würde ich schon gerne noch
ein wenig Zeit für mich haben.
Ich habe eigentlich immer
Zeit für andere ...
... geopfert.
Aber, ähm ...
Ich möchte gerne
noch auf Reisen gehen.
Städtereisen unternehmen.
Und einfach nicht mehr immer nur
unter Druck arbeiten müssen.
(Raffael) Es ist schon
so etwas wie ihr Lebenswerk.
Sie hat viel Zeit und Engagement
hineingesteckt.
Es wird schon sehr schwierig.
Aber sie sagt, sie wolle das
und trenne sich nun langsam.
Ich bin gespannt.
Es ist beinahe eine Besessenheit
von alten Dingen.
Was stellen Sie für eine Prognose?
Sie wird weiterhin Sachen bringen.
Sie wird dann einfach
zu Hause alles füllen.
Sie bringt auch jetzt
immer Zeug nach Hause.
Der Keller ist voll mit neuem Zeug.
Sie verkauft auch immer wieder.
Aber, ja, ja.
Die Leidenschaft ist da.
Das wird so bleiben.
* Schrille Gitarrenklänge *
Unzählige Gegenstände warten
im Brocki auf ihre neuen Besitzer
und ihr zweites Leben.
Und so viele Dinge, wie hier lagern,
so viele Geschichten
liessen sich darüber erzählen.
Wer sich die Zeit nimmt
und mit offenen Augen und Ohren
zwischen den Regalen herumschlendert,
wird reich beschenkt:
mit Schnäppchen, unerwarteten
Begegnungen und Geschichten
und mit kostenloser guter Laune
obendrein.
Ich brauche es,
weil mein Bruder ausgezogen ist.
Er hat das alte Fernsehmöbel bezahlt
und in die neue Wohnung mitgenommen.
Ich habe heute frei und dachte,
ich werfe einen Blick in die Brocki.
* Quirlige Akkordeonmusik *